hello guys my name is Matt and you're
watching a video on code Tecna toriel's
what I want to do today is show you what
I've been learning about doing Blender
animations and making models to using
your own code now a lot of people out
there it seems like are doing their own
game engines these days and I think
that's really cool when I'm kind of
trying to do one as well and it's really
hard to find a lot of good tutorials on
on this stuff there are a few notably
good ones out there there's learn OpenGL
there's OpenGL dev dot-org
there's thin matrix but some of those
don't explain everything or what week
it's stuck on so I'm gonna try to fill
in a few gaps here with a little video
series and specifically what I want to
talk about is skeletal animations
because you may have seen in my last
video and I'll link it below if you
haven't that I figured out how to skin
and model things with blender and how to
basically get started with blender and
I'll link those videos below a getting
started with blender where to start and
get good at that and then some about
texturing and how to texture and export
for these common ways with OpenGL and
using using blender itself and then the
next step is basically animations and
then there's gonna be ones later down
the road like how to get colliding
working and it's all very complicated
uses a lot of matrix math but when you
when you boil it down and do it step by
step it's not so bad so in this first
one I just kind of want to show you a
blender and exporting and then the next
one I'm going to go into more detail
about how to put it into your code so
I'm gonna go to open reason here I've
built a few I have this ball animation
that I could potentially put into code
or just a bouncing ball and squishes a
little and I've carefully done the
timeline and the transformations now
this is something I can export and get
this movement going into my OpenGL code
it's also worth noting that this stuff
is really easy if you use an unreal or
Unity you literally just export it as
whatever and drag-and-drop it as what
and it just works so this video is not
for you guys yeah you're doing an easy
mode and that's cool nothing wrong with
that there's still some hard challenges
there but this is more for people who
are trying to build their own engine and
or just want to understand what goes
behind these animations especially code
wise and math wise and I want to spend a
little more time understanding the
backend of what goes on so that's what
I'm intending here and so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna switch to another one
and this is sort of an embarrassing one
let's see I've got this guy who I was
making I put a few bones in he looks
really weird I just built him real quick
and I basically was testing now let's
see just just moving some bones and I'm
not super good with blender yet oh I'm
on pose mode I need to be in something
else yeah oh geez what am i doing that's
not working now I thought it would
no God cannot change pose when rest
position is a-ok pose position yeah yeah
so okay I have this set up with some
basic bones and I have these ones just
following this so I can animate using
stuff like this do a little slap
animation nothing big just to kind of
hold oh world here and I have that over
here and I have you can do these things
on time lines like you saw with that
ball I don't have this guy so to the
timeline but the point of this is once
you can build these and link below if
you don't know how to build these oh
I'll put the getting started with
blender linked to that video it's just
it's really short and it's quite a few
blender videos but it's the findt
official ones and once you understand
most of that stuff and can make these
animations and can make your own
timelines of stuff and text your um the
next thing is putting them in your game
so once you get to this folder that's
that's a big step but the next step is
really where I've been stuck for a while
and I've been working on and trying to
figure it out I found a few good
resources and I'm using specifically the
'simple I break so I'll put a link to
that below as well and it looks a little
bit like this
so I've went over thin matrixes videos
and kind of figured out some of that and
he Muse using the colada format now in
my last video about making textured
objects for OpenGL or I talked about
this guy's OpenGL series and let's see
does model loading eventually gets the
model and loads in this dude this that's
pre-made texture from some game and a
suit guy and it works great and I
figured out kind of how to do more of
those and I talked about that and doing
the obj file but the problem with the
obj file so if you go to export
wavefront
and you can choose animation but what
this does is it actually exports your
model
all his different stages so it's one
model expert port per frame and it's a
giant file and sure you can load all
those in and you can iterate through
them and do your animation by switching
between all these models but it's not
really too efficient because you have to
load in so many models and in run
through them in a timeline like manner
so it's the so BJ format while it you
can do animations with it it's not
really very good so a lot of people seem
to go to other formats that support
supported a little better and the one
I'm gonna talk about is the colada
format
FBX apparently does it pretty well too
and I'm sure there are other ones cuz
there are so many of these but colada is
pretty great because if I export this as
a colada format I'm just gonna do is
somewhere here on my documents and now
at this point I'm going to let's see
what is a better one this random guy one
might be better cuz I've got a few more
things on him I don't have them timeline
down yet okay well maybe he won't be
better we'll stick with what we got but
okay so what you can do with these is
you can have your different animation
setup with blender and you can have
punch walk run jump and you can have all
these animations and keyframe doubt and
you're gonna it's good it's gonna take a
lot of learning about animations and if
your code or it might be better to find
someone else that specializes in setting
up these animations for you and you know
maybe get a team together sort of thing
that's eventually what I intend to do
but this format of the colada format is
nice you know show you why I gave me a
second here I pull up my documents let's
pull up that robot guy rust robot demo
you know what I call him
doc Dae yeah this here okay I had so
many files in there a trouble finding
them so if I open it with something like
notepad where I can see all the plain
text close all this stuff you'll see
this is a JSON like format and I'll
collapse some of these down there's the
assets tells you about what it was made
with but when you import this with SM
you don't necessarily need the cameras
you don't necessarily need the lights
the effects I believe that's all the
material stuff so a simple handle that
and there's images materials geometries
which i think is all the mesh or all the
vertices and stuff and controllers now
controllers is where it gets interesting
and what I'm gonna be talking about here
because this is it's gonna hold all your
timeline stuff and all your transforms
and all the bones okay I guess it's here
in library visual scenes but a sim can
handle this too importing this but it's
it's all about running it in your code
in a timeline once you get it imported
and importing it has proved to be a
little tricky but Colada does have all
this stuff whereas an obj does not so
you it has all the info you need to
translate your animation into your game
how you want once you have a bill and
the notable tutorials I found that have
been very helpful is this one here from
OpenGL dev he seems to explain it all
and walks into some code and he's to
using it as a simp as well and I'm kind
of taking this apart right now and
trying to simplify it down into my own
version working into my own engine and
and that's the toriel I want to I want
to give in the next video is the actual
code and getting it running once you
kind of understand what you need to do
so if you want to jump ahead you can
have a have a whack at this if you're
ready to animate and I've got all this
stuff ready
this is a pretty good tutorial however
if you if you're like me and this isn't
exactly working for you because you're
kind of doing in your own way within
your own code my next video might help a
lot so let's see here there was another
one that was really good oh yeah I was
gonna say I think I showed it already
the thin matrix animations thin matrix
is an indie dev he's made some great
games well one that I know for sure
aquila Knox I know he's working on Maura
so he's he's a cool indie dev that's
worth fall on if you haven't just kind
of a blind shout out I've watched a lot
of his videos I love the guy as you can
see I'm build but he's got tutorials on
on these animations as well and while he
doesn't talk about specifically using a
sim in the Coolatta format he's doing it
in Java the math is all still the same
doing the transformations is all still
the same so it's it's pretty the
equivalent of this just you got to do
some conversions with the language stuff
I'm gonna be talking about C++ and I
assume he's doing it in his own custom
way which is awesome too so those videos
are good too
and yeah I want to take some time and
get this right and make it good so if
you could please give this video a
thumbs up share it with people if you
want subscribe hit the bell so you can
see when the next one comes out I do all
kinds of tutorials here I do occasional
rants on code and Tech Talk technology
and about the field in general and I
just recently made a patreon so if you
could check that out as well if you want
to you're welcome to become one of my
first patrons that would mean a lot to
me I'm still working on getting perks
set up but this would help me continue
to make videos and avoid going out and
getting a real job and and doing this
instead if I can because I love doing
this this is uh I don't know I feel like
this is me but it's it's hard right now
I'm a small Channel obviously I don't
make any money or anything so doing this
patreon thing would help me a ton but if
you can't I totally understand no big
deal I'd still appreciate some of the
other stuff that's free to do like like
and share in the video and and get in
that sort of thing or you're leaving a
comment or even just watching the video
is cool too so
just want to put that out there so look
out for part two of this it might be a
while I'm gonna try to get that all
together for you guys in the meantime I
might be doing some C++ tutorials I've
been working on a beginner series so
that's uh if you don't know how to do
C++ at all that might be a good place to
start I try to explain everything and
the most layman terms I can or at least
get a different perspective on it and
I'm gonna try to do the same with these
animations well that's going to do it
for this video thank you for watching
and hope to see you guys around soon
peace out